is there a world where hey i check into
a hospital
for xyz reasons um because my arm hurts
um and there's an ai that looks at my
electronic medical record my emr
and says okay based on this you're
probably going to have six weeks of
potential recovery and you get pinged
the second i walked into the hospital
but we fast forward
firstly i mean it's very likely we'll
have kind of a
user interface at home or even in our
pockets which is
um either automatically collecting
information about
the different key symptoms and vital
signs alternatively we'll just
type into it some of the issues we're
facing and it will triage us
either we'll come up with some
recommendations of things that we can
try out or it will suggest as the next
level up
we should have an appointment with
someone we're starting to see that for
many conditions
ranging from mental health to
longer-term conditions such as
cardiovascular disease
digital solutions are available that
will just set based on
your current diagnosis will recommend a
daily routine
what you can be eating and drinking
behavior change and even certain
medications
that a person can take and that means
that actually the whole healthcare
process and experience is potentially
managed
by that person themselves
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks
i'm zach grauman i'm your co-host today
we are continuing our series
called the future of and today we're
talking about the future
of health care what we're talking about
today we're hyper focused on the future
of
home health care workers and how we
deliver care
to an aging population which i'm
passionate about for a number reason one
is talking about future labor and future
work something we ran for president on
one of the reasons we ran was
what is happening to our labor force but
it also touches entrepreneurship
and tech and thinking outside the box in
an older industry and one of the
takeaways to talk about this episode is
that the people creating the products
in healthcare tech specifically are not
the people who are the end user so if
you're designing uber or you're creating
peloton or cameo or any of these newer
tech startups you're a user of the
product but in healthcare
you've got young innovators and young
entrepreneurs creating products that are
for very
either tech averse or older older
customers it's a fascinating dynamic so
today we've got
someone who is truly going to impress
you and he's one of those people that
makes you
makes you ask yourself the question what
am i doing with my life um he's that
impressive so dr ben
mayor thapu who's the founder of sarah
c-e-r-a it's a
at home healthcare tech company but also
he's worked in government he's worked in
policy he's been a resident he's an
actual doctor he's been a resident
physician
he's worked in machine learning he's got
this incredible perspective for someone
so young
and this is a topic that i think we all
need to focus on and how it hits us
because i'm
33 i'm an elder millennial if you will
my parents are late 50s pushed in the
early 60s
and what happens to them and how they
receive
care is going to hit my life very hard
and if you're a little older than me
it's going to hit you sooner maybe for
any some of you listening now it's
already hitting you and the future of
health care is going to impact us all
we need to talk about it we need to
understand it we need to prioritize the
right initiatives
from a government standpoint from a
resources perspective in the finances
and the entrepreneurial
innovation it touches so many different
aspects of our lives so
i'm excited dr ben is i mean his
definition of
just a world-class innovator and in some
ways a real life superhero so
the future of healthcare with dr ben
marithapu here
on yankspeaks right now
[Music]
welcome back to the next episode
on our limited series the future of and
today we're talking about the future of
health care
and honestly there's not i don't think
there's more of a broader
topic we could dive into the future of
but i wanted to
at least take a certain lane on the
future of healthcare and find someone
that
touched so many different aspects of
healthcare which i'm proud and excited
to have dr ben mayor with thapu
on yang speaks today dr ben welcome
to the show welcome to future of hey
zach great to be here how's it going
we're good you know living living the
dream as they say
um i'm glad to be with you and um
you know i was just saying how you
touched so many aspects of health care
where both um you've started an
organization called sarah
um so you're an entrepreneur you're a
doctor
you've worked in policy you've worked in
ai machine learning you've done all
these
work government organizations
non-profits um for-profits like that
that's a rare perspective so some of my
my best friend my best friends in the
world is a
pediatric um heart surgeon or uh there's
probably a fancier way for me to say
that um
but he one of the things they've told me
as a doctor is it's hard because they
feel like they can't pick their head up
and they're doing great work but they
don't always get to see the big picture
because they're literally just helping
people on a daily basis so i'm so
curious
tell us a little bit about your
background and how you went from what's
called the med school
educational path into now
literally cutting edge ai like startup
technology in entrepreneurial space
tells us of that
yeah for sure i mean clearly i have a
short attention span based on everything
you just said no shame in that
i think um so i first became interested
in healthcare it's kind of
you know almost a couple of decades ago
where
when i was a teenager i started i i
worked in a hospital for a few weeks
just to try it out and i had no
intention to
work in a hospital long term but it was
something that
um you know my school was organizing
placements you kind of had to do one and
so
that's what i did and i worked in a
local hospital
kind of did work experience and focus on
cardiology
and actually i was amazed at how what
you learned about
in the classroom and the power science
could have
to transform people's lives because even
what we
would consider now is pretty basic bread
and butter medications around blood
pressure
or around people's cholesterol and
they could completely change a person's
future
and they may come into hospital in an
emergency
where they may have had a heart attack
and through the medications they get
within hours
their outcome and what's going to happen
to them weeks months years down the line
has been
to change on its head and that's why
we've seen in many countries
cardiovascular mortality being slashed
and that was my first
eye-opening experience into healthcare
and i think
the amazing opportunity it provides to
kind of change someone's life
and then i went to med school i kind of
trained in the uk and the us
and when i was in the u.s what i thought
was phenomenal was how
um everyone that i came across it could
be a student
could be a nurse could be a bioscientist
everyone had something innovative that
they were working on they were all
everyone was working on a new startup or
a new idea or a new invention to try and
change the way
healthcare was being delivered and
that's because
at that point in time you know going
back 10 plus years
um we were starting to see the digital
revolution
take hold of many other sectors airbnb
was
picking up pace more and more people
were starting to use facebook uber was
starting to expand
and all of these household names when it
comes to technology in the digital era
um were popping up and it was clear that
in healthcare
sooner or later um a similar revolution
would come about and when that came
about it would completely change the
face of how we deal with medicine
how we look after ourselves how we think
about health how we think about
longevity as well
and then i moved back to the uk practice
as a doctor and
kind of fell down to earth a bit where
when i was practicing
in my early years as a doctor i would
spend my mornings following
um the attending or the consultant with
kind of
pen and paper notes and writing up
everything they're saying and writing up
the management plan as we go from
patient to patient to patient
and then the afternoon a similar
kind of story of again writing out many
many forms for that person or the
patients we were looking after
requesting different tasks and again
mainly spending my time on
administrative duties and i kind of
thought to myself
i spent all these years um studying
medicine
spending time in hospital walls spending
time in family care physician practices
and now i'm just really you know writing
down what a lot of people are saying and
kind of
doing admin work rather than necessarily
trying to focus on directly improving
people's lives
and i think that served as a trigger
point for trying to look at
other ways of improving people's health
at scale
and so i then i kind of branched into
policy um
where i was fortunate to have a royal
advising ceo of the nhs and nhs is kind
of our key health system here in the uk
so did you just fall into that or what
like you're you're at
what were your back up a sec what was
your what did you study in med school
and
what did you end up starting out as in
terms of your focus
so my undergrad was in uh pharmacology
okay and um then i did my clinicals
which was
covering all sorts of topics from kind
of dermatology to surgery to general
medicine
through to um looking after people in
the community through to mental health
um i spent some time in the u.s studying
both
health policy and using data to analyze
um how innovations technologies and
different interventions in healthcare
can improve healthcare
and then and that was on the east coast
in boston massachusetts
then i came back and yeah i started
practicing as a doctor
and it was a bit of a tough slog
initially if i wanted and then you
ended up so how'd you end up in you said
with an nis
uh nhs so the national nhs national
service yeah is kind of like it's about
95
of all healthcare services in the uk
it's the main system we have
uh for providing healthcare to people
and it's free at the point of access
and that's kind of an important piece
that uh
brits are proud of i mean the nhs
actually ranks
ahead of kind of the royal family in
terms of what it makes people
feel proud of being british oh
man don't i'm just going to not talk
about this today because you're going to
get
the rest of us americans very upset with
how many of us go bankrupt because of
health care costs so you end up advising
there um and
usually from an entrepreneur perspective
entrepreneurial perspective
at some point you get a bug um when did
that
itch start with you was it further down
the road or
what happened there i think i mean it
first started when i was on the east
coast
um and seeing all these people i mean
everyone
could be again to a student in their
dorm room trying to build
kind of a new platform for trying to
manage um parts of diabetes
all the way to kind of a surgeon coming
up with a new medical device
for treating people and helping with hip
replacements
i mean that was a massive eye-opener for
me and it was phenomenal
i loved it and then i it made me realize
the power that innovation technology had
to revolutionize healthcare
but it was only years after that when i
was in policy
that i started getting more
entrepreneurial so i set up something
called the nhs
innovation accelerator which focuses on
getting technologies into the nhs at
scale
because the nhs ironically even though
some people go on about it being
being one of the biggest health systems
on the planet it looks after about a
million patients a day
ironically getting scale in the nhs if
you are
a new innovative technology is really
tough um really
and that's because of regulation it's
because it's a bit fragmented it's
because of ways of working
it's because some people are kind of
almost against using innovation
culturally
um and so i tried to build a program
that explicitly focused on spreading
tried and tested technologies
essentially no-brainers that were
cheaper and offered better outcomes
across the nhs to bene benefit patients
and within about six months that
benefited
three or so million people so it really
scaled
super fast and that's because i think
there was a huge hunger in the nhs
with especially more forward-thinking
clinicians and frontline staff
to adopt innovations because in
healthcare you've got this
this really strange challenge where on
the one hand we are treating people
technically better and better they're
living longer and longer but on the
other hand
the demands for healthcare services are
only ever increasing
and because of those increasing demands
healthcare costs are going up
as you've just mentioned and in almost
any health in almost any country we're
spending
and countries are spending more on
health care than they are arguably
anything else
and it's increasing at faster rate than
any other sexual industry which is
probably not sustainable
[Music]
all right this episode of yank speaks is
brought to you by better help
i am a happy customer of better help
right now so i'm not going to say the
name of my therapist because that might
be weird but i'll pretend her name is
sarah
and she's amazing and it's like this for
me it's a combination of
just someone to talk to a bit of life
coaching
i do it once a week i look forward to it
honestly
and what i find it's like a healthy
outlet instead of just
thinking this stuff in your mind you've
now gotten it out there and you decide
for me it's like i decide what is worth
focusing on what's worth improving on
and what's worth getting rid of and
never think about again
so people can use this for depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
trauma
anger family conflicts you name it it's
convenient it's confidential
so if you want to start living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people
including yours truly
who have taken charge their mental
health again that's betterhelp.com
help slash yang betterhelp.com
[Music]
in entrepreneurship in silicon valley
there's this mentality and we had this
on the early days of the campaign
for andrews like move fast and break
things right don't ask for permission
ask for forgiveness right just go go go
and that works in a lot of ways and and
for a society you're almost forgiving of
that right like
if you look at facebook or google where
they were like darlings in the beginning
and now they're kind of villains because
we gave them a little runway and they
you know say what you will um but in
healthcare
moving fast and breaking things means
moving fast and probably killing people
right or really really seriously hurting
people's health like you can't be that
cavalier
in healthcare like how how did that
mentality
kind of bake into to where you um
frankly ended up starting your own thing
you're right and i think i mean for
silicon valley i think there are some
learnings there
because it's tough to move fast and
break things but then actually
if we look back in the history of
healthcare we do see some of the answers
so we look at how
new medical devices or surgical
techniques have been rolled out
from x-rays to mri machines if we look
at
how new drugs and medications have been
rolled out as well we have a lot of
innovation in healthcare
um that has bubbled up across different
countries
and different parts of healthcare and
once we
evaluate and show that it's relatively
safe it's about having a clear mechanism
for rolling that out at scale
because i think many systems are great
at having if they've got a new
blockbuster drug to tackle lung cancer
making that available nationwide but if
we have
a revolutionary technology or
a digital platform that allows people to
receive mental health treatment
on their smartphone and it does it's
been shown to improve outcomes
actually rolling that out is pretty
difficult
and we haven't created the networks and
the pathways
to make that happen fast and i think
that's
that's the balance we need to be able to
evaluate
and safely develop new innovations and
solutions
but once we've demonstrated they're safe
we want to be able to roll it out super
fast
so that everyone who can benefit from
them
does benefit from them so
is that a policy issue is that a
business
issue is that a bureaucracy issue what
what solves that all of the above
great so i i it's it's not i mean it's
not straightforward i think if we look
at healthcare
it's it's complex it involves a lot of
stakeholders
it's regulated and all of that tends to
slow a lot of innovation down and even
i mean if you take how let's say apple
innovates the iphone
um the people who are using the iphone
and the people who are building it and
the people who are trying to think of
new ways to
optimize different features are all the
same people very frequently
and they'll all be people who are buying
their own um smartphones and then
they're going home in the evening and
maybe
they're kind of trying out a new app and
that
tight alignment between those
stakeholders makes it really easy
to innovate to improve to adopt i think
in healthcare it's very different
the people who are paying for healthcare
are sometimes different from the people
who need healthcare
who are different from the people who
are administering or prescribing it
who are in turn different from the
people coming up with new solutions
right
you've got patients you've got
professionals and physicians
you've got health insurance companies
hospitals
and then you've got people who are
focusing on different forms of r d be it
research scientists to data scientists
to developers
to people building startups and so
creating that alignment
and the challenges with it i think are
some of the reasons why healthcare
hasn't been able to transform
and embrace technology in the way that
many many other sectors already have
and it's been a bit left behind the
challenge that
creates is how we also build businesses
that align with government policies
because again
if healthcare is more complex it takes
more time to build successful businesses
that are sustainable and that has an
impact on business models it has an
impact on how they're funded on venture
capital
um and you one requires or needs to be
more patient
it's very difficult to see the growth
that we've seen with ride sharing
also occur with healthcare services
or digital first healthcare services and
that's why i mean we need a combination
of
governments and policymakers working
with entrepreneurs
so that we can create long-term
sustainable solutions in healthcare
otherwise frankly entrepreneurs and high
quality entrepreneurs can be turned off
building solutions in health you just
hit something really really key i never
thought of before
and i imagine most people think about
that where almost every other business
the people creating it are a form of a
customer
or usually the customer you know if
you're creating an app you're creating
something that you would want to use
right you're solving a problem in your
life if you're a chef and you're going
to cook something great
it's probably because you love food
right and so there's a certain
connectivity between the creation the
process of creating it the delivery of
the creation and then the actual end
product
but if you're trying to
let's say cure cancer let's say and
alzheimer's
or als or what go down the list right
you by definition
don't have that disease you don't have
that
problem realistically because if you're
sick you actually can't most likely
create that so the
there's a disconnect i imagine between
the creator and the end
user that's so void right you imagine
this army of young people
who understand new technologies helping
80 to 90 year old
americans who grew up in a generation
that that didn't have that am i
am i hitting that right that's what
that's i think you're saying you're
exactly
right exactly and that's kind of one big
challenge in healthcare i think another
one
is that unfortunately the people who
need healthcare the most
are usually the ones who are least
likely to use technology
right to your point someone who's got
severe dementia
they're in their late 80s they've had a
hip replacement
it's unlikely they're going to just pop
on a fitbit and start monitoring their
health
right and and that presents an
additional entrepreneurial challenge but
it also means that
if we're not careful healthcare can
actually widen inequalities
because it's the healthiest people who
are going to use the latest technology
um rather than addressing those
inequalities talk to me about
your company sarah because what i love
about your company is you tie it to the
human side because you're doing a lot of
at-home healthcare work which is some of
the most important
and less almost like least talked about
form of work
a lot of people think we can have an
army of home health care workers
um when it's a really really hard job um
it's physically taxing it's
demanding it's uh sometimes infuriating
um tell us about what you've done in
like how you've looked at that
that lens we're just talking about where
like the disconnect in healthcare
products and healthcare
innovation creation if you will yeah so
i had the entrepreneurial bug
and i think after my spend spending my
time in the nhs
i realized there was this disconnect
between the people who were receiving
health technologies and the benefits
from them versus people who really
needed it
and i think it hit home the hardest when
my mother actually fractured her
back and she needed care and support at
home
and we as a family we tried to organize
it
and it was really difficult um because
we tried calling different home care
companies and i did and
most of them were just too overwhelmed
and too busy they had
people they were already looking after
they didn't have carers available
um and even when i called them and and i
said hey you're busy but do you mind
dropping me a line back
sometimes it'd be days before they
called me back and that was a real shame
because
and a challenge because at a point of
crisis you would go to a care company
for peace of mind but actually
they were making the journey more
difficult and it's not because they're
not motivated
i think there are a lot of very
motivated very resilient very good
hearted people in the care sector
it's just that they don't have the tools
and if you walk into a typical home care
agency
they're literally using a whiteboard pen
and paper
to manage their day-to-day operations i
mean i've been in home care agencies
where they don't they're not even using
the internet um and
so with those tools or lack of it
becomes really difficult
to manage your day-to-day and to
organize for caregivers
to visit people in their homes look
after them and then go to other visits
it's like lyft trying to coordinate its
operations
without using any form of technology no
one has smartphones yeah
it's like you're yeah it's i mean it's
almost impossible right and
so that was i mean that really hit home
and that kind of
for me was an inspiration for trying to
build
a digital first home care company um
that really was able to push the
boundaries
on empowering older people to live
better lives in their own homes
rather than going to care homes or or
hospitals or elsewhere
and to use technology to give people the
tools they need
so that they can provide great care
rather than being continuously
overwhelmed
and caught up with administrative work a
bit like when i was a junior doctor
and i spent most of my day um doing
admin and paperwork
rather than actually focusing on patient
care so when you in your model
you can find but i'm assuming your
mother could sign herself up but you
could probably do it for her
as well like that kind of bridging the
gap exactly so we
digitize the whole care process from how
someone's on board to how carers are
recruited to the matching of carers and
users based on
different characteristics such as time
location the skills of the care of the
needs of the individual
automating a lot of the back office
which takes the headache out
and also digitalizing the user
experience for everyone involved
the carer the person receiving care
the family member all of them have an
app that they can use to monitor and
manage the
the service and it also from a
headquarters an operations point of view
it gives us real time insight
into the care that's being provided in
someone's home and that's really
important because in a typical
home care company a carer will visit
someone in the home and
they will ride up using pen and paper
notes everything that happened in the
visit because they're required to by the
regulator and then go to the next one
but if something's gone wrong or the
carer doesn't know what to do
apart from calling up the agency which
many of the times
they're too busy speaking to other
carers or trying to sort out sort out
another issue that's cropped up
apart from calling them they have no way
of contacting anyone and getting support
and that's an incredibly disempowering
experience if you're a carer
to go and visit someone let's say
they're more drowsy than usual they
haven't been taking their medications
you don't know what to do
and then you've got to go to your next
visit that is a really i mean it's a
very concerning it's quite a scary
position to be in
but by simply using our app our carers
can communicate with other carers they
can communicate with our team and the
family and all happens in real time
so what is normally a disempowering
experience becomes one
where they feel comfortable they feel
safe they feel supported in delivering a
great care
and that's how we've used digital and
we've seen loads of metrics improve as a
result
from the quality of the care to the
staff experience to the way we're
retaining staff so that
doubles actually after we've rolled our
app and given people it
to our ability to identify health issues
in the people we're looking after much
much earlier on because everything's
digital everything's real time
it's all connected as opposed to using a
very traditional system
which sometimes takes weeks to pick up
an issue
and it fundamentally allows us to
provide a safer
higher quality and more peace of mind
service
um that also is financially more
sustainable
uh for the sector as well we're able to
pay caregivers better
we're able to charge less for care it's
a system that hopefully works in the
best interest of everyone
because we've been able to use
[Music]
technology
today's episode is brought to you by
athletic greens
it's the most comprehensive daily
nutritional beverage i've ever had
and it's so simple need a little energy
you need a little pick-me-up just worked
out
want to have some better wanna your
vegetables better you're not eating your
vegetable enough you just open
these packets pour a little in some
water throw it back sip on it throw it
in a smoothie it tastes great it's great
for you
one tasty scoop of athletic greens
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food source
ingredients including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend that's my favorite and more
they all work together to fill in the
nutritional gaps in your diet increase
your energy and focus and aid with
digestion to support a healthy immune
system
this is also preventing you from having
to take lots and lots of vitamins so
here's the deal we are doubling down on
supporting your immune system with
athletic greens during these
winter to spring months so we're giving
our audience a free supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit our link
today you'll never have to buy vitamin d
again so visit athleticgreens.com
yang join health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters around the
world
make a commitment to their health every
single day again
athleticgreens.com yang get your free
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs today
how are you guys able to kind of to your
earlier point how are you guys able to
find
scale are you now you've had this
innovation it works
you've got your metrics you've got
better results on both ends but both the
care worker and the patient
um and the cost like this is great this
is your trifecta if you will
um how'd you scale given the
bureaucracies and challenges we just
talked about
yeah i mean i think we're fortunate in
home care where
there is just a massive demand for it
with the aging population
it doesn't matter people want it no
matter what they want anything
they want as any care they can grab onto
i mean in the uk as an example
there are about a million people today
who need care who are not receiving it
that's a massive potential waiting list
and in the u.s it would be more like
five times that figure it is
millions of people who need care who are
currently not getting it and at the same
time you've got
hospitals who may be packed full of
patients
and are waiting to discharge those
patients from hospital
into home but they can't because the
care companies aren't ready
they don't have enough caregivers or
they don't have the capacity to deal
with it
and that backs up the entire system you
get
patients who are stuck in hospital which
means less people can come into
the er will be admitted to hospital in
the first place and so you have waiting
lists that queue up the other side
where people may be waiting for
treatment or emergency support
but they're not getting it because the
hospital is packed out and that's in
turn because
care companies are not there when they
need them and so
we have been able to grow through
partnering with nhs hospitals
and they give us referrals of older
people who need to be discharged and by
discharging them
rapidly and safely from hospital to home
we're solving a problem for the hospital
we're solving a problem for the patient
or the person receiving care
and for us we're getting um a demand for
our services
and in that way we've been able to scale
quite rapidly
across the uk so we're now delivering
about 25 000 visits a day
and making us one of the largest um care
providers in europe actually
so we've grown i mean and that's from
zero just over four years ago
i'm curious in the training to be a home
health care worker
tell me about how how they get trained
or are they certified elsewhere or do
you certify them how do you find your
home health care workers and what's the
qualifications there
so we um we out do the outreach
the recruitment the training the
onboarding the vetting we do everything
and that's because um the caregivers are
the lifeblood of our organization
yeah we're all about supporting them as
much as possible exactly and you want to
be able to
ensure that um we're identifying kind of
people who are
really motivated by doing a great job
and
providing great care service and
hopefully you've got a good amount of
experience under their belt as well
and that means having a very rigorous uh
approach to recruitment
and but also we've digitized most of the
recruitment and training
process which allows us again to do it
much more scalably than
a typical care company how long is
training
so the training's actually continuous
they have an initial
um kind of one week online and offline
training
program and then after that there's
continuous training which they do online
and a quarterly basis
and they'll catch up with us in person
to
um to continue their development and we
have a whole career pathway
for our carers so that um
it's not just kind of a one-off almost
transactional relationship
but we are investing in them and
allowing them to build
a professional career over time you
don't need a university actually someone
with no experience and care
can join and within a short period of
time start working on the front line
and delivering care services and for us
you're right i mean if we look at the
global pandemic
we've seen on the one hand a care crisis
and a health crisis
which also has really shown the light on
how
short we are of caregivers and care
staff
and especially when they themselves
become ill
it makes puts even more pressure and
more difficulty in how we support older
people
and on the other hand we have an
economic crisis with unemployment going
into
several millions regardless of which
country you look at
and we've tried to at cerro we tried to
use technology to actually bring those
two crises
together and create a solution where
people who've lost jobs
in airlines hospitality retail we've
put them on our training platform put
them on our recruitment platform and
allow them to get
jobs in the care sector both working at
sarah but also even for other care
companies
so that they can have a steady income
they can be back at work
and they can make a difference to
people's lives which is
really important now more than ever
because of the pandemic and
as part of that we partnered with
british airways we partnered with virgin
atlantic
we partnered with a number of different
companies so that if they're going
through a tough time and having to do
restructures and having
unfortunately to let people go they're
giving those people also
an opportunity to have a very fulfilling
career in another sector
like the care sector and that's where
we've come in
how much does a home health care worker
at sarah make on average or minimum that
high end well how's that work this time
i mean in dollars it's up to about 15 16
an hour and but if it's kind of
depending on the type of care that it
can be
more than that and as they receive more
more training and become more
specialized
that hourly rate increases further and
because of our
systems and the way we operate again
people can choose whether they want to
work five hours a week
or 30 hours a week and we can keep them
pretty busy
um given the demands that we're seeing
and i think to use an analogy i mean in
the last
in the economic crisis in 2008 i think
the gig economy was always born out of
that
and lots of um roles and opportunities
for people to get back to work
be it for ride sharing food delivery and
others came about
we're seeing that actually coming out of
this economic crisis
the care sector is potentially that
opportunity where people can get
work hopefully relatively quickly and an
income
should they need it right and it's
fulfilling theoretically
right or most times absolutely
okay last time i did a hello tushy ad
which we love the new york post wrote a
piece on
this and so i'm hoping they do it again
so new york post if you're listening
here's a hello tushy bidet
ad for you and it's awesome the future
of toileting has arrived okay it's
actually been around for centuries but
they've been very expensive before now
hello toshi has brought the cost down
and the new hellotoshi 3.0 modern bidet
attachment is here to level the playing
field it's stylish eco-friendly easy to
install and affordable
so it this new one actually like cleans
itself before and afters they've got
this smart spray automatic like
self-cleaning nozzle which is
awesome so it attaches to your existing
toilet no electricity no additional
plumbing
and cuts toilet paper use by eighty
percent hello toshi is good for the
environment
big fan of the days um you also get a
one year 12 month warranty so
check it out for a 60 day risk-free
guarantee and our listeners can go to
hellotushy.com
yang to get 10 off a bidet plus free
shipping so get 10
off plus free shipping get your butt
clean
and hello tushy dot com hello digi.com
yang that's hellotushy.com i'm so
curious because this is a challenge we
had
on the campaign and and i've always had
it we did we have this massive volunteer
army that are that are great the yang
gang we love them
and we would joke erica mccloud who's
our
kind of organizing and she um or was it
humanity forward
and she used to say um i love this
analogy she's like we have a
a url and we have an irl we have a url
challenge an irl challenge so we have
url which is online and then irl which
is in real life
and what she meant there was like you
had people that are really active on
twitter or certain places but then when
it came to like
getting out there and actually knocking
on doors or getting signatures those
that was a completely different group of
people
generally speaking um or and the
realities were different really that she
was getting at
were there times beginning days where
the irl and url didn't line up and you
guys had a flip on the fly or
or change things up how did that how did
that learning process go for you as you
built it
i mean we had so many learning
experiences be a complete roller coaster
journey right i think
even in the beginning we started more as
a marketplace
so if you wanted to organize care for
one of your grandparents you'd hop
online
go to our website and we'd have a list
of caregivers in your local area that
you could
organize yourself to visit your loved
one the challenge there was it didn't
actually solve the problem
because most of the time
people need care seven days a week if
they have difficulty getting out bed on
a tuesday it's going to be the same on a
saturday
and carers typically work part-time so
you'll need a couple
at least and then if they fall on well
or let's say
they need to take their child to school
they can't make the visit and you i mean
maybe you're kind of busy
at work having to deal with that and
organize all of the
logistics around that it's i mean it's
it's challenging and if it means that
let's say your grandfather that morning
isn't going to get their diabetes
medications
that's really concerning and that's
probably not
um the experience that you're looking
for
rather i think most people we realize
quite early on want complete peace of
mind
they want someone who's going to take
care of everything including
you know end to end you we want you to
kind of recruit the caregiver make sure
they're completely safe fully trained
ready to go
and if there any issues along the way we
want you to take care of it and if i
look back to my own experiences in
organizing care i wanted the same i
wanted
peace of mind i didn't get it and that
was probably the big user need
and so we had to pivot from a
marketplace to more of a
technology nation
exactly right yeah exactly and that was
a that was a major change
and then i mean we've tried rolling out
different product features
and we do this i mean we do this every
week and even now and we're learning
that there are some features that really
stick and that others that people just
don't want to have
um i think we once had a companionship
phone line that we introduced so that
if an older person wanted to talk
someone they could call in
um alternatively we would call them on a
regular basis and
they didn't want that because they
wanted the in-person support
they wanted someone to come and visit
them they wanted to be able to see them
and to talk to them
and that goes back to what you were
talking about how the in-person element
is so important
and i think that's something more
generally for healthcare we look at
ai digitalization genomics
even new devices that's allowing people
to kind of monitor and manage their own
health care
but at the end of the day there's
nothing like someone putting their hand
on your shoulder and saying hey
it's going to be okay so okay
theoretically you got a bunch of home
health care workers
and a bunch of sick people who need help
you can create algorithm machine
learning to completely optimize
the way these massive demand home health
care workers a massive amount of
patients
interact with each other right let's say
the human side is there's
i'm sure there are times where you have
a sick patient who really wants
dr ben to come every time they really
want
sally to come every time right and the
algorithm maybe didn't
probably didn't work that way initially
like how did how do you balance the
like human connection piece um
and do people find that disappointing
find that challenging find it exciting
to meet new people how's that work
yeah zach so initially um we didn't
focus so much on that
and we realized it was kind of a key
user experience
change that made a big difference and so
now we
solve for continuity and we always try
and ensure that the same individual
group of individuals
look after that um that individual the
person who's receiving care
and we also tend to have almost kind of
mini clusters or teams of caregivers
who tend to overlap a lot because that
allows them to build
relationships and this is where
technology
has to drive and support the in-person
part and the relational part
of care rather than necessarily creating
a barrier
and it's almost it needs to be invisible
and fall into the background so it's
effortless
in the same way that when you use your
smartphone i mean there's a
huge amount of complexity that goes into
making it work but it's because it has a
very straightforward
user experience and it's something that
you can always take it out of the box
and start
working with it immediately no one needs
to really teach you
how it works and in the same way with
care and how we're supporting our carers
we need product features in the user
experience this naturally
allows them to use our app and that's
why again this is another learning
whereby
initially we built an app that we
thought would be great
but we realized carries didn't like it
and um
and so really sitting down side by side
so that all parts of the app and every
feature we're building
solves their day-to-day problems and the
tiniest problems they're experiencing
that's so important it's not only
important for just improving
functionality it's important for just
encouraging adoption
so that they don't see it as something
they have to use and i think where
technology and healthcare has gone wrong
over the past years or even decades
is technology has always been forced on
people
and it's very clunky there's no real
focus in ux
and as a result people hate using it
they don't see it as a solution to the
difficulties they have
have on a day-to-day basis and the
frictions they go through and they see
it
as an additional burden and
i mean giving you a very simple example
so on our app
we have a button that a carer needs to
click when they check in
to visit when they land at that person's
home and when they leap and initially
it was just a button and sometimes they
would have pocket check-ins
so they wouldn't be at the person's home
and they'd check in and
that was a real problem for them because
um they only wanted to check in when
they are
actually at the person's home and for
regulatory purposes it's got to be
accurate
and so we converted that into a slider
where they got a slide
90 of the way um to actually check into
that person's home
and that small feature made a massive
difference to what our carers thought
about the app
because firstly they knew we were
listening to them and responding to it
but secondly
and it went from a product that actually
made their diff their
day-to-day more difficult to one that
made it more easy
all right if you've been listening the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about my helix mattress
andrew talks about his well helix has
left the bedroom and started making
sofas and they launched a new company
called all form
and the sofas are awesome
so you can customize this thing online
you can get up to an eight seat
sectional i've got a gray three seat
couch with like a long kind of leg
extension ottoman situation
and i love it you can spill on it like a
dumbass and it doesn't stain
it's comfy like a helix mattress it
looks amazing and
look honestly it was so easy to assemble
i'm an idiot when it comes to stuff and
it's built like a rock it's fantastic so
find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com they offer a
forever
warranty literally forever and you get
100 days to decide if you like it or not
and all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners at allform.com
yang that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m
dot com slash yang get your 20 off
get your awesome sofa couch whatever you
want it's amazing you won't regret it do
[Music]
it
healthcare's so fascinating because it's
there's the logistics where it's like
does it work or not it's like black or
white
and then there's the point of care the
touch my dad is a biomedical engineer
works a lot with pacemakers works a lot
with doctors great surgeons um
and there's a certain point particularly
in surgery where it's like
it's it's almost black and white like
did you
did you fix the valve that was broken in
the person's heart did you put does the
pacemaker work or not right
period the end but on the other end what
makes a great doctor
is how they interact with their patients
right where it's like making them feel
okay
calming their nerves like a lot of the
the lack of bedside manner if you will
can actually cause future health
problems that they're stressed the
entire time they need to be calm working
on recovery
you can go down the list and in your
if you think about a delivery app the
example i i love is like
on one hand like amazon i just need to
get the package at the front door it
doesn't particularly matter
some ways but i have a i used to live in
new york city and i had two buildings
one was in the front one was the back
and i was in the back building
and there would be delivery people um
who'd come
and deliver food and if they had never
been there before
they would get lost in the front
building and it was a pain on them it
wasn't fun for me i had to go find them
i always felt terrible
and there was no familiarity or touch
or learned kind of bedside manner if you
will in the technology to say hey in
this building
if there's if they're in the our
building wherever it is it's to go
through the the courtyard right
now it doesn't particularly matter it's
just food but when we're talking about
people's lives these
touch points these care points and they
matter right then in some ways they're
different between life and death their
difference being like a massive
massively better quality of life or not
the question i'm getting at is where
does technology go in the healthcare
space and
can we get that bedside manner piece
right
on healthcare in tech yeah i think i
mean so taking a step back
at the moment we have a global shortage
of healthcare professionals
right i think at the moment there's a
shortage of around 4.7 million
physicians
if you look at um somewhere like um
africa
it's got 25 percent of the burden of
disease but it only has four percent of
healthcare staff
and so i think the first role that
technology can play
is simply empowering healthcare
professionals to do more
and to prioritize better i think
the more we can do to take some of the
burdens and the pressures
that nurses physicians
carers physiotherapists are having on a
day-to-day basis
so they they are really focusing on the
needle movers of the healthcare
experience
calming someone down making them feel
better
diagnosing the issues they may have with
and the conditions they may have with
clarity and moving swiftly
to a very accurate robust management
plan and
and that's where technology comes in and
i also think
this is where a lot of focus for
artificial intelligence
has been present over the past years
where
i think artificial intelligence has a
role in both
helping us predict who's going to get
certain health conditions
before they do so we can be much more on
the front foot it's got a role
in helping us diagnose from decision
support to physicians so that again they
can be much more
focused on the person in front of them
and have all the things all the facts
that they need at their fingertips
to even the use of ai in diagnostic
imaging like
x-rays and retinographs finally to
using artificial intelligence and
machine learning to help
us be much more specific about how
someone's health is managed
is there a world where hey i check into
a hospital
for xyz reasons um because my arm hurts
um and there's an ai that looks at my
electronic medical record my emr and
says okay based on this
you're probably going to have six weeks
of potential recovery and you get pinged
the second i walked into the hospital
and if the diagnosis you're tracking and
the diagnosis hits and you are ready to
offer sarah as soon as i'm i'm ready to
leave is that what you're talking about
or even more futuristic
if we fast forward significantly to the
future i mean the way i see it is
in general healthcare like many other
sectors is moving
to the home right we used to go
physically to our bank we used to go to
travel agents we used to go
to shopping malls now everything's
managed online it's managed at home it's
managed
on our smartphone and i think in a
similar way we fast forward
firstly i mean it's very likely we'll
have kind of a
user interface at home or even in our
pockets which is
um either automatically collecting
information about
different key symptoms and vital signs
alternatively we'll just
type into it some of the issues we're
facing and it will triage us
either we'll come up with some
recommendations of things that we can
try out
or it will suggest as the next level up
we should
have an appointment with someone and
that could be again telemedicine
so it's in your home or that person be a
nurse doctor
a dietitian will come and visit you in
your home when you need it
so you get that coaching and support and
then after that
um even without the human intervention
it's we're starting to see that for many
conditions from ranging from mental
health
to longer-term conditions such as
cardiovascular disease
um digital solutions are available that
will just set
based on um your current diagnosis will
recommend
a daily routine what you can be eating
and drinking
behavior change and even certain
medications that a person can take
and that means that actually the whole
healthcare
process and experience is potentially
managed
by that person themselves but they don't
necessarily need to go and see someone
they may even have very limited human
interaction to your example the
diagnosis could just be remotely signed
off
by a physician who's in a completely
different part of the state
or different part of their country and
has a number of
different recommendations that it needs
to sign off and then you're monitoring
and managing
your own health condition in your own
home which is a completely different
model for healthcare
and way more sustainable and then of
course there will be some instances
where we need to go to a health
center for let's say an a diagnostic
test which could be
you know having a camera um be it being
put in you to
see if you're kind of if your gut's
looking as it should do
having a having your um an
echocardiogram for your heart to check
if it's beating appropriately
or having even a surgical intervention
but apart from those very hands-on
invasive interventions everything else
can be monitored and managed
potentially in your home by yourself
that is amazing and we change everything
yeah it completely changes everything
and i think that's
what i think digital plus kind of data
has to offer to the
consumer experience in healthcare i
think the other big game changer is
going gonna be around
um 3d printing of tissues
so we're starting to see already people
are 3d printing
bladders um trachea so your windpipe
but i think if we fast forward some
years actually if
if you've got a challenge with uh your
pancreas which could be diabetes you've
got a challenge with your heart
um or you've got an issue with let's say
your kidney
rather than taking medications 5 10 20
years
you just get a new organ printed and
replaced
and you just keep replacing it just in
the same way that
if one of the devices that you have that
you're using
needs kind of a new battery pack or new
memory and you're changing it for
yourself
that will also turn healthcare on its
head um because instead of continuously
trying to treat and manage conditions
we're curing them by just replacing
those organs all together
yeah you've got a failing heart we just
replace it immediately we don't have to
wait for a donor
i was laughing kind of as you're saying
this because how futuristic it sounds of
like being able to on-demand healthcare
all the time but
just for those of you listening i've i
used to work with very very wealthy
people on my wall street days parts of
this exists for the uber wealthy and
what you're talking about is
with the right technology and management
supply and demand you can actually
democratize this for everybody which is
um and keep getting better and better
um you guys can do this in the uk
and you've done this really well and
what maybe one of the reasons you have
universal health care
so the gig economy is um
something people can benefit from
because they don't need a job
they can be flexible with their job
because they don't need the benefits um
they don't need healthcare benefits from
their employer like we have in the
united states
thoughts on sarah being able to bring
this to the united states
and i also think that's important for
other companies as well
because if you're talking about scale
you're talking about supply and demand
making this a global platform could
potentially be a game changer too
thoughts on international expansion for
sarah and other healthcare companies
yeah zach so we're actually looking to
internationalize this year
to another country in europe we're
looking at a couple of targets but
because we've got so much scale in the
uk i mean the market is huge but
it's we also see the global and
international opportunity
to provide kind of a a more digital
first a more sustainable
higher quality quality model when it
comes to aging well
most countries are in deep need of this
and so we are
looking to internationalize this year i
think the us
is in our longer term ambitions because
of the
the way health care is is paid for and
the system itself being quite complex
especially when you look at it on a
state-by-state basis
it's something that we're more patient
about but at the same time i mean
the u.s is in deep need of a long-term
solution
to aging and to caring and i think
now with unemployment as high as it is
and we may see kind of
longer-term effects of the pandemic and
the economic crisis
that obviously provides us with a chance
to provide people with new jobs
and and that's why we did actually
partner with
care.com and another company in the us
to launch a similar
jobs initiative there that we did
compared to the uk where
we were supported people who lost roles
in hospitality airlines retail and
others
so that they could get roles uh in the
front line of care and that was to
create 10 000 jobs but i think there's
a much bigger potential opportunity when
it comes to care and also this
future model of healthcare in the home
where people are monitoring manage their
own health conditions
with some input from physicians nurses
and
carers but a limited one and that really
allows us to flip
healthcare on its head to make it much
more sustainable
and to make it frankly more convenient
and higher quality compared to what
people currently have
well dr ben i i applaud you because it
seemed i met a number of
frankly biotech and health tech
entrepreneurs and you were one of the
ones that is really doing this for right
reasons and you and you guys have proven
that both with your
the ten thousand jobs work you did for
the u.s the united states but also
you've done a lot of work on
you know people in the uk not getting
vaccinated because they're not in
hospitals even though they'd meet all
the profile
the criteria um to be an early you know
vaccine candidate
my takeaway here is the future of health
care is going to be like this
combination between our humanity and the
cool tech and
um matching the supply and demand of
health care and and that point-of-care
bedside manner ability of tech to really
customize and um deliver health care in
a in a very human way
what is exciting you like what um when
you look at this five
10 20 30 years from now what really gets
you excited not i mean maybe it's sarah
in itself but also just in the future of
healthcare and technology in the space i
think i mean a lot of things exciting me
i think
the genomic revolution is something that
we've been talking about
for even decades but only now starting
to heat up
which allows us to completely change how
we understand people's health
and our ability to know whether i mean
at
almost the point of birth whether what
someone's health is going to look like
30 40 years down the
line and hopefully shift how we're
supporting and managing them
accordingly i think the the data
revolution as well
um and we talked about ai but i think
that's
so powerful because if you we can build
algorithms that are able to support
individuals in monitoring managing their
own health better firstly that's
extremely scalable at a time where
healthcare at the moment is not scaling
well healthcare has a massive backlog
of people it needs to look after demands
only going through the roof
and it allows us perhaps for the first
time more than ever before to look at
people and support them holistically
instead of a person seeing a
cardiologist and then a
gastroenterologist and then the hip
surgeon
to actually take into account all of
that information together
their health information their genomic
information how they're doing now how
they're feeling now
and to provide them with like with the
best possible steps forward
to monitor and manage their own health
for them to look after themselves
that's going to completely change
not just allowing people to live people
longer but allowing people to live
better which i think thus far we haven't
completely cracked i think most health
systems
focus on sickness and minimizing
sickness rather than maximizing health
and all of these pretty game-changing
technologies as they get put together
will allow us to make that leap i'll say
this document
the future can be very bright here
frankly because of people like you
um you have my full support and
hopefully the yang gang's full support
you'll find out in the in the comment
section i guess of the youtube page or
or uh or
my twitter feed or maybe yours
potentially how this goes but look from
the bottom of my heart um
thank you for joining thank you for
letting me pick your brain thank you let
me ask you
very simple questions and um speaking in
uh
language that that i could understand
i'll have you back on i'll be back on 10
years
um and i'll see how right we were and
hopefully we're just my our blinds are
so blown and how fast things have
changed
and hopefully for the better so um thank
you thank you
best of luck with all your work go back
to saving the world and we will talk
soon
awesome thanks zack really appreciate it
[Music]
you